- [Narrator] If you doubled in size,
your weight would be eight times greater.
That's the trouble with growing tall.
Gravity's pull is keeping us all down,
but there are a few earthly giants
that have fought gravity and won.
(gentle instrumental music)
The key to growing tall is
how you use your energy.
That's why the tallest trees
outrank any animal on Earth,
because trees spend all
their energy on one thing;
growing taller than
their fellow neighbors.
And there are two trees
that are the best growers
of them all: giant redwoods
and mountain ashes.
Redwoods are renowned as the
tallest lifeforms on Earth,
but some experts think that
mountain ashes could grow
even taller if humans would
stop cutting them down.
In fact, the tallest mountain ash was just
one meter shorter than
the tallest redwood.
Unlike plants, animals spend
energy on all sorts of tasks,
like eating, walking, and staying warm,
so they can't grow as tall.
But it doesn't mean they're small, either.
If you measured this African elephant
from shoulder to ground,
it would actually be
taller than a giraffe,
but thanks to their long, strong necks,
giraffes are the tallest animals alive.
And if we look at animals
throughout Earth's history,
dinosaurs eclipsed them all.
These towering sauropods were
the biggest of the bunch.
In fact, the top ten lists of tallest
animals in history? All dinosaurs.
But what if we looked at
the longest lifeforms, too?
If you balance the longest
saltwater crocodile on its nose,
it would tie the giraffe.
And if we ignore legs it gets even better.
Tip-to-tail, the green
anaconda nearly doubles
the height of the tallest giraffe.
But these land-dwellers have
nothing on animals of the deep.
Supported by water, sea life
can practically ignore gravity,
which means they can grow much larger.
Take the blue whale, for example.
It's the most massive animal of all time.
For example, the entire cast of Broadway's
The Lion King can fit on its tongue.
But it should be careful
not to get tangled up
in the tentacles of a
lion's mane jellyfish,
which makes the giant squid
look small by comparison.
Now, the biggest fish
alive is the whale shark,
and if we look into the
past things get even bigger.
So where do humans fit into all this?
Somewhere near the top, actually.
Humans are bigger than
87.6% of mammals on Earth
and the average Dutchman
is the tallest of them all.
So there's no reason to
ever feel small again,
especially if you're from the Netherlands.
(gentle instrumental music)
Fun fact, the longest
life-form of all time
isn't a plant or animal at all.
It's a honey fungus and
the biggest one goes on
for 3.8 kilometers underneath
a forest in Oregon.